you mentioned in an interview that
science is not a collection effects by
constant human struggle with the
mysteries of nature what was the first
mystery that you can recall that hooked
you that kept the Christmas tree that's
a good one yeah I remember that what did
the fever for three days when I learn
about the cut and a little geometry and
I found out that you can do all the
construction in geometry using algebra
and I couldn't get over it I simply
couldn't get out of bed all right so
what kind of world is analytic geometry
unlock well it connects algebra with the
young geometry ok so the cat had the
idea that geometrical construction and
geometrical theorems and the assumptions
can be articulated in the language of
algebra which means all the proof that
we did in high school and trying to
prove that the three bisectors meet at
one point and that ok all this can be
proven by general shuffling around
notation yeah that was it's the
connection between the different
mathematical disciplines that they all
know to move into devious languages yeah
so which mathematic discipline is most
beautiful is geometry it for you both of
beautiful they have almost the same
power but there's a visual element the
geometry being of a visual it's more
transparent but once you get over to
algebra then the linear equation is a
straight line this translation is easily
absorbed and to pass a tangent to a
circle you know you have the basic
theorems and you can do it with algebra
so but in the transition from one two
and
was really I thought that the card was
the greatest mathematician of all times
you